good rot work they took everything is
funny
where are you balance let's go and get
myself and see anything they stole my
dog a delicacy in my country arrest
I never said that you thought it when I
need your help John okay where extra
Underpants why so we want the Dover
[Music]
Shantay one Lupe took the dog the
briefcase gone Michael Caine you buying
their I'll give you dog back can't
address on Google at all what are you
doing
I gotta go steal back to drugs and get
my dog back when it come something fun
could be dangerous maybe I'll die I've
got a boner for the first time in the
year
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
24 hours you probably don't care but
you're saying 24 but your hands are
actually saying 42 no no is that wanna
go to him cinnamon roll I'm John and I'm
a sex addict hello uh yeah just love sex
I love getting it I love giving it I
love it too much and I and I get it too
much that's my main problem on that sex
road got my thumb and waiting to get on
one of the sex cars
I am also liking about 40 hours a week
but on sex not just jacking off this guy
okay full-blown sex and actually come to
think of it it's more than 40 hours so
I'm doing time and a half yeah so you
get paid my overtime I'm gonna obviously
I'm not condoning sex for money that's
bad right we all agree would you good I
really just had sex with any little
thing that comes my way there's some
supplements obviously age 18 and allows
no no bueno
oh good upwards so it's where I really
shine 50 60 80 90 Centennial okay thank
you for sharing John
you